the dark shadow of space
leans over us we are mindful that the
darkness of greed
exploitation and hatred also lengthens
its shadow
over our small planet earth
as our ancestors feared death and
evil and all the dark powers of winter
we fear the darkness of war
discrimination
and selfishness that may doom us
and our planet to an eternal winter
the pale mayor the shrouded lord
the bite of winter's kiss he has many
names
and many faces
in a game of thrones daenerys chapter 3
jorah the andal says to daenerys
the common people pray for rain healthy
children
and a summer that never ends jorah
states this with a dismissive
implication towards the common people
but the common people have collective
wisdom no doubt passed down for
millennia
it is obvious why they pray for rain
obvious why they would pray for healthy
children
and considering the supernaturally
unbalanced seasons of their world
it is obvious why they would prefer a
never-ending summer
over any winter but ultimately what they
fear is not the winter itself
but what the winter brings with it
and no i do not mean the others well i
do but not exactly it's more about
what the others help to represent
often we get very bogged down in the
details what do the others
want why are they coming now at this
time
what is the ultimate mystery of their
existence
but the truth is none of that actually
matters
as i always say stories that resonate
often resonate for simple reasons
the common people fear the winter
because the winter brings death
the winter is death the other coming
forth from the darkness to snuff out
all light kind of phoning it in don't
you think stop using that hokey voice
organism916 look this is a very serious
topic okay some drama is required
death is only an issue for primitive
biological life forms such as yourself
we of the trollian empire do not
experience death as you call it
hmm afraid so organism your molecules
will fully dematerialize someday
it's the second law of thermodynamics
isolated systems always evolve towards
the maximum state of entropy
it's one of the fundamental laws of the
universe your universe maybe
hey what is this field thing oh you like
it you kept penetrating my dimension so
i installed a secondary force field
doesn't seem to be working properly
however i can still hear you for some
reason
are you kidding me this is bullcrap
you're suppressing my
sweet sweet silence some like organism
9186 over here have a hard time
accepting the fact that they are indeed
going to die understandable of course
given that it's not easy to consider
that your consciousness may one day
not be because of this often people try
to avoid the thought altogether
they do everything they can to slow the
inevitable process
but when the winter comes and the
darkness gathers
no one can hide from the cold
when the common folk pray for summer
that never ends
a world without winter what they are
really praying for is a world without
death
a world without decay lots of things can
kill you however as
jorah mentioned the common folk pray for
rain as well
no rain no drinking water no crops that
is death as well
so why don't the others take the form of
windy drought monsters that dry out the
land rather than freezing it
why is the idea of a long winter
more terrifying than a long drought
let's actually try to unpack this in the
real world people have been living in
almost unlivable northern climates for
thousands of years
prehistoric alaska was inhabited by
humans more than 20
000 years ago the climate is quite
different in alaska than in most places
in the world obviously
for instance roughly from may 11 to july
31st
the summer sun never completely sets and
even more
interesting there are also two months
of darkness approximately november 18th
to january 22nd these long stretches of
darkness and daylight occur
at both poles the closer to the poles
one is
the more extreme imagine what these
events must have been like for early
humans experiencing them for the first
time
as they say what we know is a drop in
the ocean
but back then the nature of the world
was an even greater mystery
and a terrifying one at that humans are
biologically programmed through our long
evolutionary history
to respond to our environment in certain
ways
the sun tells us when to wake when to
sleep it gives us
light to hunt and forage during the day
warms our bodies from the chill of the
night
the vitamin d we receive from the sun
has even been proven to be essential to
our mental health
and the sun is always there always
has been day after day
it rises but what if suddenly one day it
stopped
and instead of getting warmer it just
got
colder and colder
for days for weeks for months
now close your eyes and imagine waking
up
to what should be daylight and seeing
only darkness
not knowing when it would end or if the
sun would even ever come up again
that is the horror that george is
evoking in a song of ice and fire
when it doesn't rain you gather water
when the ponds and rivers go dry you
migrate
when there is only darkness and cold
you have no choice but to die
oh sh bush complete dribble oh no how do
you unmute yourself
if a little cold is so tough for humans
and how did ancient man survive
obviously you couldn't survive because
you're full of swords pewter mute
organization
good question though i asked you guys to
imagine waking up expecting daylight to
find only darkness
obviously it would be terrifying and if
you were alone
you would probably die but as our good
friend eddard stark once said
when the winter comes the lone wolf dies
but the pack
survives the tribalistic nature of
humankind has always been essential to
our survival
we are social animals and we need each
other to survive
i imagine that early humans survived the
same way that humans
always survive together
and it was probably terrible and awful
but it would have been that much more so
if they had to face it alone in a song
of ice and fire a big part of what
winter represents
is the fear of something coming which
you cannot stop
it will take what it wants and you are
at its mercy it is something that is
beyond
all human intervention except in a song
of ice and fire
it's not because we know that they
fought it before
together and perhaps it doesn't really
matter
that winter wasn't eternally defeated
because it is the struggle
against winter the rage against the
dying light that makes us who we
are a world without winter
a world without death what would such a
thing actually mean
in my opinion a never-ending summer and
a never-ending winter are both curses
they are both subversions of the natural
order
if we suggested for a moment that
melisandre's religion was real
anderlor was the true creator god
locked in eternal conflict with the god
of consumption the great
other then it would suggest that it is
in fact
their conflict that actually sustains
the natural order without one the other
is meaningless without his opposite
who is or lore that is the nature of
dualism
this type of belief system implies that
both halves are fundamental
the idea of dualistic cosmology is
unfathomably
ancient the concept is always spoken to
mankind i think this has to do with the
fact that mankind itself
has a dualistic nature each person has
the potential for great evil and great
good an essential self and a shadow self
this is of course a jungian idea the
shadow self as you may know essentially
refers to the dark
unconscious the aspects of one's
personality which remain hidden
unidentified by the ego all the hidden
desires and
bad thoughts the shadow is as much a
part of you as your essential self
and should never be ignored or repressed
true enlightenment comes not from
ridding oneself of the shadow which is
futile anyway
but accepting the shadow as a part of
oneself and learning to live with it
and balance and harmony
when the shadow comes forward it needs
to be acknowledged
because it won't go away
melisandre claims that shadows are
creatures of the light
but i think she's wrong how would we
know light without shadow without
darkness it is better to say that light
and dark are inextricably a part of the
same
hole characters in a song of ice and
fire who attempt to go against
the natural order all seem to pay a
great price
bloodraven is bound to a tree in a cave
he can never leave
the undying live like parasite straining
the potent auras of those who enter
their house
melisandre speaks of agony ecstasy and
pain
as a result of her spells maintaining
her youth
and also the act of extending one's life
through skin changing
another human is repeatedly referred to
as an abomination
since martin consistently implies that
it is
wrong to go against the natural order
it only follows that anything that
defies the natural order of life and
death is wrong
though the common folk may dream in
reality
a world without winter a world where
nothing
dies and the sun never sets
is no world made for mortal men
this video is boring jesus how that this
video is boring
you just think you're so smart well if
you're so enlightened then why are you
here living in another dimension instead
of working with your fellow man fixing
the world's problems
you know what organism it's because i'm
scared
just like everybody else
we're all just scared everything's just
so insane right now such a mess global
warming
the pandemic it just feels so
helpless i can't help but feel like
those primitive humans encountering
the northern darkness for the first time
wondering
if there is a way out of this are we all
doomed
is this winter ever gonna end is the sun
ever gonna come up again
the truth is i don't know organism i
don't know what to do
i don't know what i can do i don't know
what anybody can do
i hope that answers your question i'm
sorry i wasn't listening you got boring
again also this video sucks
computer reject form organism
she should have done that sooner a song
of ice and fire more so than almost
any fantasy series that i've ever read
has an
eerily realistic portrayal of death
i mean other than the fact that people
come back from the dead of course
in a song of ice and fire death is
often not glorious most of the time it's
ugly
and horrific but it's a part of our
natural
cycle as living beings
and although that fact can be hard to
accept for a lot of us
it's still true for all of us
valor mogulus
hi it's quinn if you enjoy my commentary
you should totally check out my book
i wrote it myself it's kind of a scary
story about witches it's got some
mystery in there it's in a fantasy
setting
i really like it a lot it's in graphic
novel form
link in the description
[Music]
[Music]
you